this is a production of Cornell
University
okay so I'm going to be talking about
the push-pull system which are in in
sub-saharan Africa and it's I think this
is a really interesting example of
ecological intensification as an
approach to solving the challenges of
production and so many of you know that
this really is my first time being
involved in research in a developing
country and smallholder subsistence
farming systems I've traveled to you
know many countries for workshops but
this is what I decided would be really
interesting to become involved in for my
yeah so I'm going to just speak briefly
about ecological intensification as a as
a framework in an alternative path for
addressing some of the challenges in
agriculture an introduction in a tour of
push-pull systems some of my preliminary
research results so this research is so
far being conducted on Fulbright funding
which is you know rather limited for
actual data analysis and then some
future directions and collaborations
that have come out of it so we know
we're facing some big challenges in
agriculture and I really don't have to
go over them for this group and there
are many solutions that are being
proposed and we can sort of you know
think of them as a continuum starting
with the more crop per drop so the idea
that we continue on our current path and
improve the efficiency of the resources
that we're using another alternative
that's proposed is ecological
intensification so this idea of
restoring ecological integrity as a way
to address some of the problems and
there's many sort of a continuum in the
middle in reality we're going to need to
draw from both of these approaches so I
don't see them as mutually exclusive so
I'm I'm and ecologists I'm particularly
interested in looking at ecological
intensive
and trying to learn more about you know
how far can we push these approaches and
the central hypothesis of this approach
is that we could use biodiversity to
enhance and restore some of the
ecological processes that that support
yields in productivity and be able to
reduce the fossil fuel-based inputs that
we're using so address some of these
issues of environmental degradation and
also food security at the same time so
there is some evidence that you know in
going in this tour in the trajectory
towards intensification and the you know
amazing increases in neil's that have
been achieved that there have been
reductions in in biodiversity talking
mostly about plant diversity which then
has these cascading effects on
arthropods and the below ground
communities so one graph is from the
Midwestern u.s. the corn soybean belt
over a number of decades and then
another is some work that was done in
Germany looking at plant diversity on a
somewhat smaller scale and this trend
can be found in many other landscapes
that as you intensify you increase the
tendency towards monocultures either you
know continuous monocultures or maybe
alternating two crops but you have
extensive landscapes in mostly in the
same species or one or two species
and this kind of intensification was
enabled by replacing the ecosystem
services that were once delivered by
plants for example nitrogen fixation or
weed control so as perennials and other
species are removed we can use
fertilizers we can use er besides to
actually increase yields even in that
you know without using that plant
diversity for those outcomes and so the
question is can we go in the opposite
direction can we increase plant
diversity and have an impact on how much
energy and I'm using it as proxy for
inputs on the inputs that we're using
can we can we go in this direction can
we get tangible benefits by managing
plant diversity at multiple scales so
within the field the farm and across
landscapes and there are some evidence
that's link that links biodiversity both
in space and time to improvements in
yield they've been a few studies that
have actually looked at some energy
biodiversity relationships I'm just
going to put up three examples here ones
in in Africa in the same sort of region
where they were looking at biodiversity
both in terms of intercropping and
rotation and its impact on yield and
another study is that came out it mainly
focuses on pollination i would say that
pollination as an ecosystem service and
the impact on those crops that require
pollinators is probably the best example
and the most studied case where we can
link biodiversity across landscapes and
at farm scale to concrete benefits in
yields and you know we can go in either
direction some people study landscapes
and look at you know how homogeneous is
a landscape need to become before it
impacts yield negatively they find that
you get to landscapes that have fewer
and fewer kinds of species plants and
have
have reduced abundance and numbers of
pollinators and reduced yields in the
pollination dependent crops these are
going the after opposite direction and
in the most recent study which was
carried out across many regions on you
know multiple continents found this very
strong relationship between plant
biodiversity pollinator diversity and
abundance and yield and it did vary
depending on the size of the farm so
there's some intricacies in here that
the entomologist care about but this is
just suggesting that we need to
understand more about these processes
and look at how far can we push it and
how can we use these methods to
complicate to complement the inputs that
we're using and this is particularly
important for those smallholder systems
where you know they don't have the
resources at this point to purchase all
of these inputs so I have been aware of
push-pull intercropping system for a
long time I used it in my AG Recology
course as an example of where multiple
ecological mechanisms are used to manage
pests and this is a Zarek on who's the
scientist who's been working on the
system for 20 years and he developed it
along with a number of collaborators
summit rothamsted in particular and this
this system was developed by the bios if
a which is a small NGO that's based in
Kenya and works in the region of
sub-saharan Africa so he's my mate it's
iffy as my host institution in Kenya and
aircon is my main collaborator so just a
little geography here's Kenya straddling
the equator I never been there before i
went to actually start working and
visiting these farms sfa is located over
in western kenya
red x's right on lake the shores of Lake
Victoria and that that's their second
research campus they also have an office
in Nairobi and then the area where they
work is this this region of western
Kenya which is a humid a semi humid
tropical climate there's there's quite a
lot of variation in the rainfall that
actually occurs there anywhere from
eight hundred to sixteen hundred
millimeters and in most locations it's a
bimodal distribution so there's two
growing seasons however very far up
north there's one long rainy season up
near khatauli and the sort of their
northern most border of the area they
work in so there are farmers using
push-pull systems in other parts of
Kenya and also in in other sub-saharan
countries but the most of them are
concentrated in that see if I can go
back in this this region of western
Kenya okay so what are the challenges
that these farmers are facing stem
borers that are a big problem and there
are many different species of stem
borers I forget there's there's more
than a hundred I forget exactly how many
there are so that that's the major
arthropod pests there are others but
that one is the biggest one that has the
largest impact on yields and then the
other serious problem is stryger which
is a parasitic plant and
Strega is actually in addition to you
know taking nutrients in carbon from
Mays plan Strega is is pathogenic so it
actually injects compounds into the
plant that caught disrupt its metabolism
so the stunting of growth that happen so
here's the strike it actually attaches
right to the maze room are largely due
to this disruption of metabolism and
sort of a you know actual disease that
develops striker has a huge impact on
yield I mean it just can decimate yields
once it gets into a field it produces
lots of seeds and it can just keep
spreading so these are the challenges
and the push-pull system is is basically
the idea is to manipulate the plants
both in the field answered on the
borders of the field to address these
constraints that that are impairing
yields and the work began in the 1990s
and at that point the focus was on the
stem borers and it began with screening
a bunch of especially grass species to
look for plants that would serve as trap
crops so that would attract the pests
and plants that would repeal the
arthropods they were looking for both of
these and this is wise called a
push-pull is sort of named after the the
main focus of managing the insects and
this idea of pushful systems has been
around for you know before the 1990s and
there was some work done in Australia so
this is not the only case where this
approach is being used but it is an
example of an extremely effective case
so by accident zircon discovered
desmodium he was just you know
collecting seeds he got some seeds
forward and he would scream you know
whatever plant species he was finding
and it turned out that desmodium not
only had
a sort of a repelling effect towards the
stem borers but also help to control the
Strega and and this was a huge discovery
because when they first began promoting
the system to farmers as of as a way of
managing stem borers the fart and it is
ecologically it is a somewhat complex
systems managed so growers need to learn
how to how to actually manage it and
they do and they also have contributed
to some of the innovations and I'll talk
about that later they the farmer said
look this is great that it controls stem
borer but you know if you can get rid of
the striker then we'll consider
intercropping and you know doing this so
it's really a good thing that he found a
plant that could actually effectively
control the striker because it by far is
the you know greater has a greater
impact on yields and is of more concern
to the farmers and of course desmodium
is a legume it's a perennial legging so
it has the added benefit of fixing
nitrogen and there's been a lot of
improvements over time to the system
from you know the beginning so there's
sound multiple species that can be used
and the farmers have pushed some of this
innovation by giving feedback on what
they need so here's just a diagram of
how the system works and there's been a
huge amount of work on the chemical
ecology the entomology in the system and
very little work on the soils so the
desmodium is planted in between the maze
Rose they plant their maize fairly far
apart so you don't they don't have to
adjust the spacing in order to enter
crap they normally intercrop food like
games commonly so common being for
example or ground nut
so they they plant the desmodium in the
middle of this to the arthropods smells
like a damaged maize plant so that's and
there's been like 11 to 13 chemicals
that are have been identified that
mediate these exchanges between the
plants and the arts of HUD's so those
act as the repelling plants the stem
borers when they go out of the field
find the Napier grass which is planted
as a border around the field that is a
trap crop that attracts the stem borers
they lay their eggs in it it's a
super-duper trap crop because it
actually ends up killing ninety-five
percent of the larvae when the larvae
hatch out on a Napier grass plant they
get stuck in some of the the honeydew
that the plant secretes it's got like
some sticky goo that it secretes near
the base of its leaves so many of them
end up dying so it reduces the the
population and then the desmodium also
releases some root exudates that
stimulate germination of the Strega
however it's a suicide germination the
Strega germinates but it cannot elongate
to connect to the maze roots so it ends
up dying why can't it elongate the seed
to buy forget the technical name of it
well the chemical that's produced by the
desmodium is for some reason stimulates
to germinate but then there's not the
next step that allows it to elongate and
I I don't that's about as far as I know
because it there are a lot of mechanisms
that are involved I have a slide of that
but I left it out so yes so that's the
main part of the blow ground work that's
been done though is on me the does mode
IAM control of the strike up so these
are just coming to show you some
pictures this is the research station
there's several long-term experiments
there
you can see the maze with the desmodium
which is quite a vigorous grower and
it's managed in ways that reduce the
competition with the maze in terms of
the timing of cutting this is also a
forge Napier grass also serves as a
forage and you can see that it's also
susceptible to the strike of the purple
flowers of the Strega and what's amazing
is these this is only like about a you
know five feet and there's there's
absolutely no striker in this field the
desmodium is incredibly effective at
controlling Australia this is one thing
we're wondering about is will there be
some overtime some adaptation in the
Strega to be able to overcome the dis
moding but so far there is no evidence
for that and once you notice the size of
the sniper grass because it's rarely on
a farm do you see the grass get to this
law this side so this is one of the
issues that the farmers are harvesting
Napier grass and the desmodium to feed
their livestock so early in the season
so the desmodium is cut back quite
drastically when the maze is planted so
it's very small when the plants are
small and then as the maze starts
growing it begins to cover but you can
see it's much smaller than was under the
large plants and then by the you know
the time the maze is large it can be a
very thick carpet and sometimes
sometimes even grow up right and this is
out in one of the farms so I want you to
notice here is the you know very highly
harvested border that's almost
unrecognizable and many farmers are over
harvesting these accessory plants so
this is one question that we want to
look at is how much harvesting pressure
can be systems bear and still garner the
benefits of the desmodium and the grass
borders and then this is an adjacent
field is another one of this farmer's
fields that she hasn't transitioned to
push pull and you can see the difference
there so the benefits have been
documented extensively by work out in
farms in terms of yield increases the
control of straw and timber and and vary
a little bit of work on soil fertility
most of the conclusions about soil
fertility or serve anecdotal or indirect
based on yield improvements in the
plants look more vigorous and we know
nitrogen fixation is going on and that's
one area i'm very interested in trying
to actually document there's significant
improvements in livestock production
because now there's better quality
fodder for them and also more of it so
both of these plants service following
this is a very important outcome and
benefit and one reason why farmers are
interested in adopting this system and
as a result there are some economic
benefits usually the yields go up
sufficiently so there's extra maze for
selling and there's work going on now
looking at how this all pans out in
terms of human nutrition so at this
point about 96,000 farmers have adopted
the system mostly in western kenya but
also in uganda malawi and tanzania
particularly in areas where strike is a
problem that's that's you know and also
some of the areas they're a little drier
where there's other
challenges and zipping has been
instrumental in disseminating this they
have a demonstration garden at the farm
where they have the system at different
stages and this is I thought some of
those extension folks might be
interested in this because this is a
complex system to manage and they can
bring farmers there for intensive
trainings and they can show them you
know at this stage you need to do this
and at this stage you need to trim this
is when you trim the desmodium and they
can actually get practice doing some of
these things so they plant they can have
irrigation so they have at least sort of
six plots they're at different stages
when you would carry out different
management they have a whole other sort
of system of educators and materials
however beyond their efforts farmers
have played an incredible role in
disseminating this technology which is
probably important in the case of
something that is this you know complex
to to manage and one of the most famous
farmers is Sarah Obama who I met I
thought they were kidding me when they
said they were going to have me meets
her Obama though they probably have a
grandmother all over the country and
they tell Americans you're going to meet
Sarah Obama but then I got there and I
saw the sign so I and I saw the military
guarding her farm so she she was active
at one point in some of the you know the
push-pull dissemination efforts but
she's pretty low key right at this point
yes so I want to show you some I think
this is where yeah i want to show you
it's just if the video works we didn't
get to test it because of all the
technical issues some so you're going to
see to farmers and these these two
farmers have been instrumental in
disseminating the system one of them
organized mary first one you're going to
see
organized groups where they you know
meet periodically talk about what's
working talk about what they need to
improve they bounce I you know ideas and
problems off of each other she's going
to talk briefly briefly about Strega and
then the next armor is called the
grandmother of push-pull by many of the
farmers in the region because she
adopted a bunch of farmers were invited
to this meeting and she was the only one
that came none of the men came so she
got trained in push-pull and she's been
you know training farmers in her
community so that push-pull farmers tend
to be in clusters she's going to talk in
her own language about the push-pull and
just split but show you two of she's got
two fields of push-pull manaan pushful
I'm going to have to hate yes
approach wife is no code yes and did you
have strike before yes that was straight
huh hey in strength big day there's
somebody beautiful duty I don't yell or
biggie pick up lies yes okay yeah idea
whoa you're there hey give me a hot bath
need to see from what number there was
like no no I know I know if you don't
how much she put on Dee milliner job
anyway it's in my small amount and find
your happen if I don't booty haha you
mind yes so she has had pushful field
since 1999 she took out one and answer
in you know rearranged her fields and
that field has been push-pull since
think 2004-2005 and as you know
sometimes they try to do experiments so
she did an experiment she put fertilizer
on push pull and she's convinced that
that helped her yield however she put
like five kilograms on the whole field
at least that's what we can understand
so this is the challenge of doing unfun
farm work because we suggested well what
if you put fertilizer in both your
fields because many and many many cases
we see fields where they are putting
fertilizer on all of their fields and on
the field station they put fertilizer on
push bulletin on push polling
it seems like the Strega is the main one
of the main issues okay so i'm working
with pretty much all entomologists in
the system i'm very interested in what's
going on with it is modi emits a
perennial legumes there's a lot of
questions about how the nitrogen is
being delivered to the maze there's two
possible pathways and the entomologists
are convinced that this is the important
pathway just because they know that
legumes can you know transfer nitrogen
to non legumes but I you know I actually
think this this may be important early
on but this probably is the major
pathway later on because we know that
you know nitrogen is going to contribute
to building organic matter and that's
another mechanism for delivering
nitrogen so these are the kinds of
questions that I started out with I was
really interested in looking at how the
does mode IAM intercropped affects the
flows of nitrogen and building organic
matter and then also looking at some of
the other related benefits of building
of the organic matter and then
understanding some of the sort of the
ecology of nitrogen fixation in the
system there's several desmodium species
there's a lot of variation and
environment and also in management
history and if we can understand this
then we could actually make
recommendations to the farmers about
when they might need nitrogen fertilizer
when they may not need it what the
evidence is that farmers are applying
nitrogen fertilizers sometimes at high
rates mostly a very low rates and that
they're they're you know they're not
really discriminating between their push
pull and their non push-pull fields so
they may put just as much fertilizer on
the push-pull fields where the leg Hume
is when their other fields really might
be nitrogen starved and in we were
seeing some evidence but adding nitrogen
suppresses nitrogen fixation when we
look at the desmodium in fields where
they put on a fair amount of nitrogen we
would just find very few nodule
than not you know active and then some
questions about how they use their land
and how much how heavily they harvest
these crops especially the desmodium and
when can they start harvesting it
heavily so I'm going to go into some
preliminary results I started with
sampling on the field station and these
are just results from free of their
long-term experiments showing about a
thirty percent increase in soil nitrogen
this is from the 20 centimeter steps are
basically the tillage layer the kind of
a surprising finding was this difference
in extractable phosphorus so both the
push-pull and the non pull push pull
systems it's a tongue twister have
received the same amount of phosphorus
fertilizer but when you do extractable
phosphorus there's this significant
difference between the push-pull and non
push-pull soils and we haven't looked at
the fractions and exactly where the
phosphorus is but that's something we're
very interested in following up on there
I've measured PA when I got there there
had been absolutely no soil measurements
done even on the experiment station so
the pH does not show a significant shift
from push-pull to non pushful except for
in one experiment which is the non
replicated experiment the oldest one and
in that one I think it's because some of
the manure they added probably has some
calcium carbonate in it but it's very
patchy patchy ly distributed and then
you know we would expect these
differences in the organic matter pools
to show up most significantly in the
active pools to the particular organic
matter and these are very important to
look at because they do have the
greatest impact on soil structure
and nutrient flows so the particularly
the occluded particular organic matter
could be an important source of
nutrients and for people that like to
see this so this is from the top five to
six centimeters just that sort of the
difference in the amount of residue
going into these soils this is from the
longest experiment so that's the the
free particulate organic matter and mean
we took these pictures for extension
purposes and then the occluded
particulate organic matter which this is
a you know a big difference be able to
see differences in these fractions is
just a sort of a testament to how
profound the you know the impact is of
having this perennial leg you so I was
very interested in collaborating with
them to do some work out on farms and
see how this this practice actually
affects the the farmer soils because
their practices I mean on the field
station we could make critique these are
optimally managed they are not
aggressively harvesting the supporting
plants I mean they are harvesting them
and they are using them for fodder
they're harvesting them in the
recommended way which is not nearly as
as aggressive as some of the farmers who
have small land holdings and really need
fodder for their for their livestock are
doing so the first the cluster that I've
been focusing on in this initial work is
located near the village of Vega and
this just gives me an idea the landscape
in this area has a rainfall that's sort
of in the you know higher to medium and
of thousands of twelve hundred
millimeters it is is bimodal and this in
this region farmers have some very small
holdings fractions of hectares so the
size of the farms varies with the region
some of the farmers in this region have
a
of an acre or so but on the plus side
this is an early adopting region meant
to say that and that's partly because
Strega was a very severe problem in this
in this area so and you can still see
you can see lots of striking and
non-critical fields office in this
region and there are some you know
fields a lot of fields started in
between 2002 and 2005 so to do this on
farm research we took fields and divided
them into at least three replicates and
sometimes if it was a large field we
were divided in half and then divide
those into three replicates so the
design because there are some rolling
topography and there are some changes in
soil types that are you know crew on a
fairly small scale our first priority
was to try to match the soil types and
so the analyses will be you know viewing
that we'll use them as pairs in order to
compare push pull and on push full
effects so I have some of the data from
the farms but not all of the the non you
know sort of the background texture and
all of that information I don't have
that yet so we went out divided them
into these replicates and collected soil
samples from 20 centimeters usually and
made composite samples at least no 6 to
12 cores depending on the size we
interviewed the farmers briefly and I
was really dependent on the extensions
to help me because a lot of the farmers
do not speak English Mary is one of the
exceptions and so our findings on the
farms are similar they're they're
similar to what we found on the
experiment station but much more
variable as you would expect given the
the differences so five out of eight
pairs showed an increase in the soil
nitrogen and organic matter
in one case it's it's reversed and and
what we hope to do is to look at how
environmental variation and also
management practices so the you know
severity of the harvesting how much is
being harvested relative to you know
remaining in the field and how that
impacts these dynamics we also found the
same result with the extractable
phosphorus and I do know that in this
pair because these farmers our neighbors
that she applied phosphorus fertilizer
and she did not and the others is very
hard to get accurate fertilizer
information from farmers and I think
we've finally figured out a way to do it
I won't tell you what it is but we've
had better success when I went back this
past June at getting information that we
feel more confident so that's kind of
where we're going with that and the last
thing I'll show you with these
preliminary results and this is some of
the early work to look at nitrogen
fixation dynamics and I mean the process
of trying to find funding because it's
pretty expensive proposition to do the
isotope analyses that are needed for
this but I did do a survey and just
looking at the Delta end shift so this
is the Delta in and as it gets to be
more positive in the des Beaux diem so
in the nitrogen-fixing plant we can
conclude that nitrogen fixation is being
reduced so it's it's the you know or
reduced proportion of nitrogen is coming
from the atmosphere that's the
interpretation and we do see this
positive relationship the longer the
farm or the soil is under pushed pool we
know the nitrogen fertility goes up and
we would predict that that would
suppress nitrogen fixation the legging
down regulates and we we see evidence
for this a pretty good relationship
there some outliers and this would this
is where you know we we would assume oh
my
in the wrong place if it was at zero
that would be a hundred percent nitrogen
fixation which week you know don't
normally see how that line move a
mystery all right do I still have five
minutes is at it okay now i'm going to
talk him faster that way so future
directions i'm going to talk a little
bit about the challenges because the
farmers are playing a really essential
role in overcoming some of the
challenges and one of the major
challenges is access to the seas or to
the materials for these accessory plants
and talking about the the Napier grass
the brac area brachle area grass which
is the other grass and the desmodium in
particular the green desmodium which is
a more drought resistant species they've
had a very difficult time getting it to
produce seeds in the you know in the
climate in Kenya there you know sort of
a problem that they've been wrestling
with and here again the farmers have
been playing a crucial role in this this
is Elizabeth Elizabeth oh dear I'm
forgetting her last name oh well I have
it written down and so she has a nursery
for the breck area grass so she's been
propagating this and you know as part of
her outreach work disseminating this so
some of the farmers are actually hired
they receive a stipend from a sip a to
perform these roles of outreach and they
occasionally take it further and
actually do problem solving such as she
realized the major issues the farmers
can't get ahold of the of the material
and I'm going to try to play one more
video of oh I'll show you her picture of
erke or comiso and her farm is pretty
amazing and when you're watching this
video you might want to just watch her
expression while the extension asst is
translating
because she's barely hanging on to not
cracking up made the farm so here's her
farm and and where I'm at the lower
push-pull field and they had planted a
lot of green desmodium at the bottom of
this field which is overgrown the back
you'll area grass and it is full of
flowers and seeds and we took some
pictures of the seeds but I think
they're having some very successful seed
production and so we don't know if it's
the material i started with or something
about the environment this is Rachel you
know yeah so Lisa this morning sleep Oh
from how this onion
she's trying it about to see if she can
admit these out of the Queen
so this is the thesis she must be able
to harvest probably just a small part of
her family and she's trying out this and
it was just part of it she's going to
tell us tomorrow from happy so there's
our adventure for TG dryers in Portugal
giant strike yeah and that was Rachel
she's the extensions from Mississippi
that I work with most of the time and
she was also my translator she did allow
the interviewing she engages in the
social science research that they say
carry out and extension outreach okay so
future research directions I promise
I'll cover it in two minutes so in terms
of the work that I'm pursuing I'm very
interested in trying to do some more
detailed work on nitrogen cycling in
these systems to try to understand the
flows and and transfer of nitrogen to
the maze and I'm also working with some
collaborators to to look at some broader
questions relating the below ground
changes that take place and put push
pull and how those affect the arthropods
that are interacting with the plan so
particularly Andre Kessler's interested
in how plant secondary compounds might
shift and that may impact these
interactions and then we there there's a
group of us that have been formulating
an idea to do some research on the
long-term sustainability in the
push-pull systems because there's a lot
of questions that come up about the
longevity and how affect you know how
these systems can continue to be
effective over time and these are so
this is sort of the core collaborators
there's Katya pavada and Andre Kessler
who are the
to cornell faculty they're both
entomologists that I'm working with and
then the folks of the supe there's
professor Khan who some of you may have
he's sort of periodically had
appointments at Cornell dr. Charles
bodega and charlie oh shoot Pitt picture
what Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy picture me and my
name is him and so and he's the carries
out the social science research so
looking at the sort of dissemination of
knowledge and how this impacts things
like labor demands and they're sort of
getting into collaborating with some
nutritionists so we're especially
concerned about two issues one is over
time and to increase the proportion of
the landscape that's in these systems
how will that possibly impact the
herbivores are these arthropods going to
become resistant you know you're just
going to over use a mechanism and
they'll adapt there's many questions
with that and and also climate change
and how that's going to impact them over
time and the climate change issue is
tied into this question about harvesting
how much pressure can you put on the
system and have it still function and
and so those those are tied together we
see those are sort of the key pieces of
the sustainability issue and so I'll
stop and say thank you and be happy to
answer any questions or listen to
comments you have
they're all rain-fed yeah they for the
most part there's not a means to
irrigate so in some cases they may you
know have water for irrigation that
they'll preferentially put on their home
garden some of the intensive vegetable
crops right in the house but not amazed
sorry that's a new story I just mm-hmm
or likely
higher yields and wet well I mean the
central hypothesis is sort of tied to
energy and inputs oh ok this seems to be
into the diversity is
oh right yeah yes right and yeah so this
idea that just a niall diversity will be
good and you know is is not that's not
really the way we view it so there's a
whole literature and this you know the
hypothesis comes out of the natural
ecosystems or unmanaged ecosystem to
work so there's different metrics that
we can use for diversity and so
functional diversity and phylogenetic
diversity those are two they're sort of
replacing species richness and just
simple number of species so good point
thank you mmm I concur with a lying that
there was a fascinating presentation
both about three foot or history system
my question is have you given any
thought to the applicability of this
push-pull system to American or North
American
vulture well actually you know I asked
the entomologist about that and so from
the pest control angle and if there's an
entomologist here who wants to add to
this or correct me i think that it's
probably not an option right now mainly
because of the maze genetics the
material we have that we're growing for
you know corn because let's see the the
signaling and the communication between
the stem borers and the maze has been
lost so the stem borers from what i can
understand from katia the stem borers in
the united states do not recognize the
signal of hey i'm a damaged corn plant
anymore at least the same yeah so so the
specific yeah right well the specific
system you know and then there's other
issues is you know with trying to add a
perennial in between the maze rose and
how that would work so we have genetic
material here that we're using that's
really adapted for the system that's in
place which which is you know has these
cascading effects on the structure and
I'm not going to kind of go anymore it
go into that anymore but the broader
question of using plant species i think
is definitely an option that we will
want to consider in you know even in
intensified high yielding agricultural
systems there there are some you know
problems that we're running to like
especially in the pollination dependent
crops we're even under high input
intensive agriculture yields are being
impacted by the lack of diversity in the
landscape in the lack of pollinators and
it can't really be overcome just by
moving honey bees around and you know it
doesn't seem to be and I think that if
we want to try to expand the ecosystem
services that we're going to get from
agricultural lands that this is is one
approach that we want to consider and we
want to think about you know where do we
really want to use nitro
fertilizer because we do need it but we
could be strategic because there's
definitely systems where there's enough
rainfall enough of a growing season to
grow some of our nitrogen and then we
would accrue these you know these other
benefits so thinking about how do we you
know I think we just have to be
strategic about where we blend ecology
with the inputs that have been developed
yes
the desmodium rennie outlet
but yeah so far they haven't really been
using inoculation I don't know if that's
because it's you know promiscuous there
are some native desmodium species that
are in Kenya and actually now so the two
they're using are from elsewhere the
most prevalent silver and green leaf
there's two pardon it yeah right yeah so
there's two desmodium species that are
native of sub-saharan Africa that
they're evaluating right now and I think
that you know taking advantage of these
different ecotypes in desmodium and also
the different species of grasses that
can fulfill this functions is a good
strategy
if they're very Asian before
yeah that's a good question that's
something I'm very interested in we
don't really know so you know we would
the right now the desma green does
modern being heavily favored because
it's rot resistant and you know we don't
really know enough about the ecology of
these species to know when might be
beneficial to have the silver leaf like
what is the what is the difference in
these in terms of how they perform in an
inner crop some farmers are ending up
with a mixture which i think is probably
a good way to capitalize and you know
because they've lost some of their
silver desmodium because of drought and
they replanted with green but they've
left the silver that's there so I think
that'll be interesting to see how that
pans out okay thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu